قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
باتريك رايدر ان اعاده حامله الطائرات يو
اس اس فورد من منطقه الشرق المتوسط لن
تؤثر على وضع القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه
واضاف رايدر خلال مؤتمر صحفي في واشنطن ان
بلاده ستحتفظ بقوه في المنطقه كفيله بردع
كل من يسعى لتوسيع الحرب خارج
غزه اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه في الاول من
يناير انه سيتم اعاده مجموعه حامله
الطائرات يو اس اس فورد من شرق البحر
الابيض المتوسط الى مينائها الاصلي كما هو
مقرر تحضيرا لعمليات انتشار مستقبليه وكما
اعلن بيان البحريه الامريكيه فاننا نواصل
الاحتفاظ بقدرات عسكريه واسعه النطاق في
البحر المتوسط وفي جميع انحاء الشرق
الاوسط وكما فعلنا ذلك منذ ان شنت حماس
هجومها الارهابيه الوحش
في السابع من اكتوبر ستستمر وزاره الدفاع
في الاستفاده من وضع قوتها الاجماليه في
المنطقه لردع اي دوله او جهه غير حكوميه
تسعى لتصعيد هذه الازمه خارج
غزه معنا من البنتاجون مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور فادي المتحدث باسم البنتاجون هل قدم
توضيحات اكثر عن سبب سحب حامله الطائرات
يو اس اس فورد من شرق
المتوسط نعم حسن الحامله فورد للايضاح هي
خرجت منذ نحو ثمانيه اشهر اي في مايو ايار
الماضي من العام الماضي من قاعدتها نورفوك
في ولايه فيرجينيا في مهمه عاده المهمات
لا تطول مهمات الحاملات الطائرات والقوات
القوه الضاربه المرافقه لها لا تطول الى
هذه المده لكنها خرجت اساسا للعمل في اطار
دعم الاسطول السادس الامريكي ومسرح
العمليات في كل من اوروبا وافريقيا وجر
التمديد لمهمتها ثلاث مرات متتاليه كان
اخرها بعد هجوم السابع من اكتوبر حيث
انتقلت مع القوه الضاربه المرافقه لها وهي
عباره عن ثلاث مدمرات الى الشرق المتوسط
لتامين مظله حمايه لاسرائيل وصفها في
حينها وزير الدفاع بانها تاتي في اطار
الردع الامريكي لاي دوله او مجموعه تفكر
في تاجيج الصراع وتوسيعه خارج نطاق غزه
وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بالجبهه الشماليه
لاسرائيل مع لبنان وفي ظل العمليات
العسكريه بين اسرائيل وجنوب لبنان تحديدا
حزب الله التي بدات في الثامن من اكتوبر
وبالتالي كانت معنيه بهذا العمل وعليه
العوده الان الى قاعدتها نورفوك في
فرجينيا والتي اعلن عنها رسميا في الاول
من هذا العام تاتي في سياق روتيني لكن
المتحدث باسم البنتاغون اوضح ان هناك
مجموعه برمائيه مخصصه للانزال البرمائي
سوف تملا الفراغ الذي ستخلفه حامله
الطائرات فورد وهي مؤلفه من ثلاث سفن
السفن باتان وماسا فيردي وكارتر هول وهي
تضم مجتمعه نحو 2000 من قوات المارينز
الاستكشافيه و2000 من قوات البحاره وايضا
50 طائره وهي قادره على القيام بمهمات
مختلفه منها عمليات الانزال البحري فضلا
عن ذلك لدى القوات الامريكيه قطع بحريه في
منطقه البحر الاحمر وجنوب البحر الاحمر
فضلا عن حامله الطائرات ايزنهاور والقوه
الضاربه المرافقه لها والموجوده في منطقه
عمليات الاسطول الخامس اي في مياه الخليج
وبالتالي تعتبر الولايات المتحده ان لديها
ما يكفي من القوات في هذه المنطقه وتستطيع
من خلال حضورها العسكري الواسم
ان تردع اي محاوله لتوسيع الصراع حس فقط
فادي هل هل جرى الربط بين
سحب الحامله الطائرات فورد
بتغيير نمط او تكتيك العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في غزه كما كانت تطالب
الولايات المتحده بان تكون عمليات اقل
كثافه واكثر
تركيزا لم يصدر هذا الموقف عن اي مسؤول
امريكي الاعلان الاول الرسمي حول عوده
حامله الطائرات فورد صدر كما اشرت في
الاول من العام الحالي وصدر من خلال
الاسطول السادس حيث كانت تعمل الحامله ضمن
قياده الاسطول السادس الولايات المتحده
تعتبر ان ما تقوم به هي اجراءات لها طابع
ردعي ولكنها ليست جزء من العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه والحرب الاسرائيليه
في قطاع غزه وتحاول ان تفصل عمل قواتها
سواء من خلال وجودها المنتشر او فيما
يتعلق بما تتعرض له هذه القوات من هجمات
سواء في العراق او في سوريا عما يحصل في
قطاع غزه وهي ترفض ان تقول بان الولايات
المتحده هي جزء من هذا العمل العسكري بصرف
النظر عن حضورها العسكري عن توريد السلاح
لاسرائيل عن الدعم الاستخباراتي وغيره من
الامور حسن